hi John good morning
it's Brotherhood 2.0 with Hank and John
Green wow that guy was having fun at 7
o'clock in the morning and I'm about to
get on a plane yesterday I was sledding
down a hill Lake Tahoe now it's fun this
isn't fun I hope you don't mind if I
make a suggestion as to how to begin our
conversation on this video blog being
your brother is kind of frustrating
sometimes this is because people walk up
to me and they say gosh you look so much
like your brother
Oh your jokes are very similar to your
brothers except you're not quite as
funny as him apparently some people even
think that we look like the twin rock
duo The Proclaimers which is admittedly
better than people thinking that we look
like the twin rock duo Nelson so I would
like to propose a list we make a video
blog list of all the ways in which we
are very very different people things
like in the last few years John Green
has gotten kind of pudgy whereas in the
next few years Hank green will get kind
of pudgy and also things like John Green
has never spilled a tiny amount of beer
on his life's map book which then
proceeded to not boot up and also John
Green didn't almost ruin the video bug
experiment by not having a computer that
would work and also John Green didn't do
the happy dance when his wife was in the
shower and he reinstalled the battery
and tried to boot it up the next morning
and it worked
and also John Green probably would have
told his wife about the incident instead
of hoping everything would turn out okay
sorry honey and also and also and also
and also John Green doesn't constantly
and vainly obsess about his hair which
apparently I do
on some level performing a version of
500 miles on this show actually does
appeal to me
punishment project or challenge